[Music]  drake and kanye squash their beef at  what seems to be drake's toronto home  dave chappelle gave a speech about drake  inviting them which was posted on drizzy  and kanye's instagram stories last night  [Music]  [Applause]  i'll say it  make some noise for kanye and drake  [Applause]  earlier this month kanye extended an  olive branch to drake and invited him to  appear at a concert to advocate for the  freedom of larry hoover who is currently  serving six life sentences related to  gang activity both me and drake have  taken shots at each other and it's time  to put it to rest  i'm asking drake on december 7th to join  me on stage there's a special guest to  share the two biggest albums of the year  live in los angeles with the ultimate  purpose being free larry hoover